génération identitaire deux mots qu'on
pourrait croire synonyme de coup
médiatique dans ce groupe d'ultra droite
est devenu spécialiste en la matière
dernier coup d'éclat en date le 19
janvier lorsqu'une trentaine de
militants se sont lancés dans une
opération anti migrants à la frontière
espagnole
des actes qui ont provoqué la colère du
ministre de l'intérieur qui a
effectivement été particulièrement
scandalisé par le travail
si j'ose dire de sape de la république
des militants de génération identitaire
qui ne sont pas à leur premier coup
d'éclat c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
j'ai donc demandé aux 5000 milles un
intérieur de réunir les éléments qui
permettraient minzah diar 2 proposera
des solutions de génération identitaire
c'est que le ministère du travail
il le fera évidemment dans le cadre des
lois et des règlements de la république
en proposant notamment une fois que ces
éléments seront particulièrement réunit
le contradictoire est dû à chaque
association
une procédure qui a donc été lancé le 13
février dernier
cette association a longtemps été la
branche jeune du mouvement bloc
identitaire
fondée en 2002 c'est en 2012 que le
mouvement est lancé officiellement et
commence à faire parler de lui
cette même année certains de ses membres
envahissent le toit d'une mosquée en
construction à poitiers fort d'un
certain succès médiatique
les opérations coup-de-poing
s'enchaînent rassemblement en 2017
devant le bataclan pour je cite la
défense de l'europe face aux islamistes
intrusion en 2018 dans un local de
l'association sos méditerranée qui vient
en aide aux migrants mais son principal
coup médiatique intervient lors d'une
vaste opération anti migrants à la
frontière alpine entre la france et
l'italie en avril 2018
on est à sion identitaire
une opération qui avait poussé dès 2019
plusieurs associations a demandé la
dissolution de ce groupe comme la ligue
internationale contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme des demandes validées
donc par la procédure enclenchée par
gérald darmanin au grand dam des
responsables de génération identitaire
cette lettre est plein d'inexactitudes
d'erreurs factuelles de mensonges et
d'un tas d'éléments qui n'ont pas leur
place dans une procédure de dissolution
si le droit est jugé nous sommes
extrêmement confiants
si par contre c'est une décision
politique et qu'il y ait un jugement
politique l'a effectivement nous avons
tout à craindre que la dissolution aille
à son terme
l'organisation qui a dix jours pour
fournir des contre-arguments au
ministère de l'intérieur devrait
effectuer ce qui pourrait être son
dernier baroud d'honneur samedi
génération identitaire souhaite lancer
une manifestation pour dénoncer c'est un
potentiel dissolution